how do you feel about putting your  children in that situation since you're  not with the mom but like I wasn't gonna  buy a choice I'm trying to say I'm not I  never chose to be a single foreign  statistics your rebuttal to me was to  use an emotional response to say oh but  you put your child in that situation  yeah but you know what I never because I  did not choose to be a single father  single fatherhood came to me you the  difference between you and I you are  choosing to put yourself at a  statistical design by putting yourself  in a single mother situation I know what  you are but the thing is you said that  but you said that though